A lot of people who might like to take a trip are intimidated by the idea,...
...either afraid of being lonely or afraid for their safety.
But every day around the world, travelers just like you are exploring places by themselves.
These are some trips you can take:...
You can take a train someplace new.
The train journey itself can make for a thoughtful solo trip.
It's comfortable, reflective...
...and even if you don't speak to anyone, you have the view to keep you company.
Go to a part of Asia where you don't speak the language or understand the culture.
It's like giving yourself voluntary culture shock or...
...visiting an alternate reality.
Traveling alone is about breaking out of your comfort zone,...
...and what better place to do that than a country that is completely foreign.
Go volunteer someplace for a month.